my my job is to try and liven things up
even though it's a relatively late in
the day and it's been a very intense and
long conference one benefit i have is
that at least the the screen is very
visible and you don't have the sun
obstructing a big part of the screen I
thought especially in light of the
earlier panels that we heard I would
start by saying what I think is not sure
but short-termism is not about and it
will help me set the stage for what I
would like to say in terms of solutions
to bring to short-termism so the
difficulty that we face as those of us
who are engaging in the short-termism
debate is that we're dealing with an
institution the stock market which is a
fundamentally for looking prices reflect
expectations of what's coming in the
future of earnings cash flows etc that
that are going to be realized in the
future so it's a forward-looking
institution we're looking at and then
it's hard to square that with the idea
that somehow it's not for looking the
right way or not forward-looking enough
anyway so that's the problem potentially
difficult conceptual problem we're
facing one important point I want to
dispel from the beginning is that
short-termism is not the same as
shareholder activism it's a separate
idea we can have a hedge fund activist
who is a long-term investor and we can
have complacent incumbent management
resting on their laurels not reacting
sufficiently fast and that's another
form of myopia so sometimes the debate
gets narrowed down to the activists or
the short-term guys management incumbent
management and shareholders are the
long-term guys and somehow they you know
they can't agree on right so i just
thought i would share this slide with
you as an introduction this is from a
piece from the economies that some of
you may have seen last week and it gives
you a nice summary of you what many ceos
feel feel like with their daily life is
today and this is especially good
picture in light of what we heard about
the media writing stories twice a day
putting out information and waiting for
it to be corrected you know that fits in
quite well with with this slide so very
much we live in a world where long-term
thinking is a luxury so as I was
beginning to to discuss short-termism is
not the same as shareholder activism and
short-termism is not synonymous with
stock repurchases that's another idea
that we hear a lot you can be a
long-term investor you can manage your
firm for the four to generate long-term
value and that may involve stock
repurchases more to the point we now
live in a world where short-termism
takes the form of excessive shareholder
turnover and you can see here this plot
which gives you the average holding
period of stocks nyac from the 1960s to
2005 this plot predates the advent of
high-frequency trading and it's not just
a u.s. phenomenon it's also a UK
phenomenon and and basically a global
phenomenon you see the shortening of
holding periods a lot of turnover and
that's one way in which short-term its
pressures have increased so the
difficulty for companies is how do you
rebuild a long-term shareholder base I'm
going to give you a few quotes first
quote from Chancellor Leo Strine it's
judge on to demand that CEOs and boards
manage for the long-term when the
stockholders who can replace them buy
and sell based on short-term price
movements that's the first point I
wanted to bring to the table John Bogle
has been advocating for a long time that
we need to enhance the role of investors
and diminish the role of speculators and
he's been advocating for granting higher
dividends to long-term investors and
he's also been advocating for
intervention in the form of capital
gains taxes which are decreasing in the
holding period of the stock here's
another important take on this question
justice Jack Jacobs today institutional
investors control nearly seventy percent
of the stock we've heard about that
earlier this today you'd think that
institutional investors are in a way
buying hold investors how do you square
that with the with the evidence I've
shown you earlier well those
institutional investors are managed by
persons of firms who compensation
depends on generating short-term returns
and to give you a sense of the challenge
for institutional investors here
Blackrock the largest asset manager in
the world a black robe Blackrock has
large equity stakes in most corporations
Blackrock has 20 specialists this is a
someone old article it's the only
information I could from New York Times
I could find but Black Rock has 20
specialists that deal with corporate
governance of the portfolio management
Blackrock and these 20 people in 2012
have voted 100 close 230,000 proposals
and that we were put forward at nearly
15,000 board meetings there's no way 20
people can do this can engage in a in a
in a deep way with companies when you
have so many proposals to deal with over
a short run time period another
insightful finding by a recent study
which tells you how average stock
holdings
differ across investors in particular
here institutional investors and what
you see here is that over the period 85
to 2010 Berkshire Hathaway had an
average holding period of stocks which
went from 2.5 years to 4.5 years but
definitely a Berkshire Hathaway lies
above everyone else and who's everyone
else here you have fidelity which had a
rich holding period less than two years
and the pension funds of Ohio and the
endowment of University of Chicago these
are long-term investors long-term
investors that are actually holding
stock at a lower horizon than Berkshire
Hathaway now why is the two year horizon
important we here's a study a very
influential study by McKinsey and here
I'm quoting Dominic Barton as he
commented on the under McKinsey study
and here's what what they found when
makenzie's finance expert deconstruct
the value expectations embedded in share
prices we typically find that seventy to
ninety percent of a company's value is
related to cash flows expected three or
more years out he also emphasizes the
fact that if you compare how engaged
directors are in privately held
companies versus public companies you
see in much deeper engagement and this
will speak to some of the points that
were raised this morning and the panel
it takes time as a director to really
become familiar with a company you're
directing and and manage it with
adequate information and then in this
context here you have the finding of the
McKenzie study they found that
seventy-nine percent of respondents felt
pressure to demonstrate financial
performance over a period of just two
years or less forty-four percent said
they used a time horizon less than three
years and forty-six percent of
respondents said that the pressure to
deliver short-term financial performance
stemmed from their boards and board
members made it clear they were
channeling short-term pressures from
investors so you see here where the
chain is going if you have very
short-term oriented investors it's going
to filter through the entire company
through the board directors through the
CEO and this is despite the fact that
over this period what we've seen is a
lengthening of besting periods for CEO
compensation I thought I'd bring in
Silicon Valley perspective on
short-termism this is a long mask
speaking about SpaceX and here's what he
said in a couple of tweets no near-term
plans to IPO SpaceX only possible in
very long-term when Mars colonial
transporters flying regularly and and
for those of you who follow the route
and use recently Jeff Bezos his company
a Blue Origin managed to land his direct
competitor with SpaceX managed to land a
rocket on its feet I just checked before
coming here Blue Origin is a privately
held company I don't think Jeff Bezos
has any plans to to bring that company
to the market so the point is there is a
lot of evidence out there or shorter
miss pressures of public markets and I'm
here to propose a new idea actually it's
not so new it's a been
out for a few years and that's the idea
of loyalty shares and I thought I would
just quickly describe the main idea and
not go into too much detail about this
about the design specifics I think this
is not the right time and and then maybe
it just conclude so here's the basic
idea you have a loyalty period that's
basically a period that a stock needs to
be held to be considered a loyal
shareholder and then you grant
shareholders loyalty warrants which they
can exercise after the loyalty period
and then you can have a loyalty exercise
period after following the loyalty
period and the big point is that if
you're buying whole investor for three
years you get the warrant if you're not
a ban hold investor you don't get the
warrant and however whether you're going
to get the warrant or not is purely
driven by investor behavior and this can
be you know this is a tool that can be
used to reward costly monitoring
postpone a costly dividend secure
strategic investor and also to
facilitate an IPO and and reduce
flipping this is all I'm going to tell
you about the design issues I can go on
forever
but what I want to point out is that
loyalty shares is really just two points
i want to point out here the loyalty
shares sometimes people mean it's more
voting rights after a loyalty period and
there are shares that have been granted
a recent example is ferrari for when
ferrari went public it granted loyalty
shares with extra voting rights that is
not a design that we're favoring we're
favoring a design where loyalty is
rewarded financially and specifically
rewarded financially through a warrant
that's the first point I wanted to make
the second point is that the you can
design the loyalty we share in a way
that it does not prevent or reduce the
incidence of activist interventions
during the loyalty period so this is not
an entrenchment device this the reason
why you want to have loyalty shares is
is exactly how Toyota recently pitched
it's double a model shares these are
loyalty shares offering higher dividend
so long you hold you hold the stock and
how did Toyota pitch it they said well
we're doing long-term investment we're
doing R&D on on sell fuel cars this is
going to pay off five years from now we
don't want investors to keep on on a
quarter-by-quarter basis thinking what's
going to happen to Toyota and to these
R&D investments I'm being told that my
time is up so I will stop here and just
leave this this slide
you